certainement pas
es-tu frère
[musique]
un homme qui est soudainement apparu
héros
Il est un survivant du roi et une fois Benimaru
de
était comme un grand frère
[musique]
le jaune est
Est venu en tant que messager du royaume de Rajashor
Si cela continue
Le royaume Rajasho périra-t-il ?
Je veux que tu me prêtes ta force
je
Je fais aussi des tomates reines
C'est un poison de réanimation qu'on ne trouve pas dans la nature.
avec ce diadème
Il protège les gens du poison, mais il
force dangereuse
J'ai besoin du chaos
[musique]
Tragédie Petit pays Grand secret
Toutes les personnes
Es-tu prêt
[musique]
Version du film
Cette fois, je me suis réincarné en Slime
Liens cramoisis